because no obviously Steve Carrell
percentage but you really did it I mean
the hair the weights good look right how
long did you have to look like that for
a long time months and months how did
that go down at home not well turn off
the light darling intruder tonight
[Applause]
now the Hulk weirdly no prosthetics for
the Hulk but in green suits yeah and new
prosthetic so you just wear the green
people ask me all the time like how long
did you have to stay in the makeup chair
for that did you did did you have to
work out for that but are you aware of
all the concern online amongst the Mark
Ruffalo fans about what the finished
Hulk would look like I know all my fans
by name you know their concerns you know
their worries now there was a lot of
concern amongst the mark of an offense
that the Hulk would not retain his
beautifully pursuit chest they thought
he might be hairless Oh but happily the
The Hulk has got some hair it's the
first Hulk in the history of moviemaking
all three movies yeah all two of them
now where where the Hulk has body hair
it's a revolution it's a revolution it's
really we're doing some of
groundbreaking work you probably
familiar that mark since you are a
campaigner for the hairy chest your
problem here with the there's a site
called hairy chest I want to cry on
there really is there really hit your
producing team may be aware so you you
are front and center on this I think you
look really like Lenny Kravitz
That's not me it's not really not you
that's Lenny Kravitz is it really no
don't mess with my head the person who
ever posted this but it'll comment on
the side mark ruffalo more like mark
buffalo look at that Harry hi
speaking of Buffalo I want to drive his
body to the verge of extinction
what was that person's name
[Music]
you